moderna abrió una nueva batalla legal
sobre la tecnología de arn mensajero
esta vez denunciando a facer y bayón te
presentamos estas demandas para proteger
la innovadora plataforma de tecnología
arn mensajero en la que fuimos pioneros
en la que invertimos miles de millones
de dólares para su creación y que
patentamos durante la década anterior a
la pandemia de kobe 19
la farmacéutica considera que facer y
variantes copiaron dos partes clave de
sus inventos primero una modificación
química particular sobre la rn que ayuda
a despertar una respuesta inmune
adecuada y segundo la codificación de
una parte de los corona virus que usan
para infectar las células y que es
necesario codificar para saber contra
qué debe protegerse el cuerpo sin
embargo vayan tec asegura que todas sus
invenciones son originales y también
fruto de años de investigación sobre la
rn mensajero una tecnología que se ha
usado comercialmente por primera vez
contra la pandemia de kobe 19 y que
podría abrir las puertas a nuevos
tratamientos por ejemplo contra el
cáncer
moderna prometió no implementar sus
patentes de la vacuna contra el commit
19 en los países de ingresos bajos y
medios pero desde marzo de este año
reclama que su propiedad intelectual se
respete en los países ricos hay un tema
financiero un tema de intercambio de
beneficios entre compañías y desde el
punto de vista de ciudadano yo estaría
muy tranquila moderna ha dejado muy
claro que no va a poner en peligro
acción de la vacuna esto es un tema muy
importante ni tampoco los beneficios en
países con pocos recursos
sólo en 2022 facer y ballón tec se han
embolsado 22 mil millones de dólares por
su vacuna moderna casi 10 mil millones y
medio